of course there's going to be some
things that have negative income
outcomes or a you know a weird thing
like a pandemic or a
comet strike or who knows what it's
going to be there'll be something that
happens in the next 30 years
that um that is negative and um
how do you want to address that in the
context of of this piece
well one of the ways i think about this
is the culture itself is just
filled with um
[Music]
all kinds of dystopian roles out in all
kinds of ways
all the disasters are going to happen i
mean any side five programs tv
shows magazine articles cover stories
and mag
all the things it is we've we're just
bombarded with this so one of the things
i'm trying to do is overcompensate and
and you know it's a conscious choice
of trying to stress that what is getting
lost in this look ahead in the future is
essentially all these positive
developments that are inexorably kind of
going along they're kind of in the
backdrop
they don't get the same drama i mean you
know the rise of middle class globally
the rise of you know the kind of
urbanization that's
a positive thing i mean these things are
just backdrop statistics that
occasionally surface and people miss
and so in many respects in this story
i'm just trying to focus on that knowing
full well
that there's going to be a completely
crazy bunch of things that are going to
come up here including wild cards
that'll set us back
um for sure it's going to happen and it
will happen it's kind of i mean
basically it's kind of the one one step
forward two steps back two steps forward
one step back i mean is this that's just
the way progress happens that's the way
technology rolls out that's the way kind
of
economic booms happen we're going to go
into a crazy period of time here and
there is
absolutely going to be a lot of negative
stuff that's going to happen and there
are going to be times where we'll be
ringing our hands thinking oh my god
it's over
but i think what i'm just trying to lay
out there is what is missing uh and
largely missing certainly when i started
this project
like you couldn't even find anybody kind
of trying to talk about the positives of
the next 10 20 30 years
i will say it's shifted differently
literally just in the last couple of
months you're starting to watch a kind
of a conventional kind of a
news way to frame that coming off the
pandemic with the pent-up consumer
demand and you're going to watch with
the
with the uh the vaccines coming together
and actually opening up
the economy again that you're going to
see some kind of a boom
i think of that as relatively short term
consumer boom kind of the beginnings of
like you say the post-pandemic kind of
roaring 20s that is a
for sure true thing it is happening and
it will happen but i think what i'm
trying to get at is these deeper things
that'll keep playing off for 10
20 30 years and that we haven't really
thought through
fully what it all means i mean when if
we are going to shift
even the vast majority of our energy
system on the planet to clean energies
over the course of the next 30 years i
mean just think of the economic
opportunity that
and just think about the scale of change
that's going to be needed and just think
of all the businesses and jobs and all
this kind of stuff
i mean people kind of know it at some
level and they kind of think okay yeah
somehow we got to do this but they
haven't really thought it through i
think when you do think that through and
you do think that through all these
other things these
inextricables i was telling you and see
them in synergistic kind of alignment
it really makes you think oh my god
maybe we are heading back into something
uh that is going to be quite
extraordinary
you